it turns out holding onto your old phone
could be dangerous so here's what's
happening a bunch of fellow Tech
creators and I have noticed that Samsung
phone batteries have started swelling up
at a rate much higher than any other
manufacturer I happen to have a lot of
phones stored here and the only ones
I've ever had to remove with swollen
batteries have been Samsung phones now
just because something happens to you or
doesn't happen to you doesn't mean that
it's statistically true at a higher
scale but the pattern here from my
phones to Mr who's the boss's phones to
Mr Mobile's phones to Austin Evans
phones is too much to just ignore so the
working Theory right now is that the
electrolyte material in the batteries is
actually slowly evaporating over time
when the battery isn't being used which
creates a gas and swells up and can
break through the back of the phone but
we're thinking that's why it seems to be
mostly affecting older Samsung phones
that aren't being used as much that are
sitting in storage if you do have an old
Samsung phone in a drawer somewhere
check on it but also in general if you
do have gadgets that aren't being used
it makes sense to actually properly
recycle them I'll leave a link in the
description of this video to help you
out with that say no to spicy pillows
because